foreign
fighting crime fighting inequality
fighting rats is something that we are
focused on as we continue to make this
city a livable City everyone that knows
me they know one thing I hate rats you
know when we started killing them in
Borough Hall you know some of the same
folks are criticizing us now called me a
murderer because I was killing rats well
you know what we're going to kill rats
rats have no place in this city and
we're going to use every method that's
needed to do so so they're not harming
families in our quality of life we are
not going to sit back and accept that we
have to be in a city where rodents are
taking care of our city we are meeting
this head on and we are going to be
willing to have a moon shot mindset of
doing things differently as we approach
this issue of a long-standing historical
issue of dealing with with uh rats and I
spoke with my colleagues in Paris of you
know same problem there rats is an issue
that we're we're facing um based on the
habits of of of human beings
[Music]